Hi.
Welcome back to recitation.
In lecture, you've been learning
about computing-- rather,
not computing, but
determining whether series
converge or diverge, and
different tests for that.
In particular, you've
learned the integral test.
So here are a couple of series
that you haven't seen before.
The sum from n equals
2 to infinity-- 2,
just so I don't have
any funny business here
of dividing by 0-- of 1
over n times log of n.
And a second series,
sum from n equals 2
to infinity of 1 over n times
log of n quantity squared.
So the question is, do these
series converge or diverge?
So why you pause the
video, take some time
to work on this
question, come back,
and we can work on it together.
Welcome back.
Before you left, I
gave you a little hint
that these might be
questions that are
amenable to the integral test.
One thing we can do--
you know, if you,
if I hadn't given you that hint,
how could you figure this out?
Well, you can look
at these integrands.
And they don't really
look a lot like anything
you've seen before.
But the associated
functions, right--
so this is the associated
function, 1 over x log x.
This continuous
function is a function
that we have-- you know, it
looks sort of like some things
that we've integrated before.
So that's one hint
for the integral test.
Another hint for
the integral test
is, you just don't know
very many tests right now.
So it's kind of a small
selection of options.
Another thing is
that, you know, it's
not going to be a nice series.
It's not going to have
a nice numerical value.
This log n thing
is behaving badly.
You're not going to be able to
compute values, exact values,
of the partial sums, any
nicer than they looked just
by writing down that sum.
So OK.
So after we've got the
idea of the integrals--
that's how we get the idea
for the integral test.
Now that we've got the
idea for the integral test,
what do we do?
Well, we know that this
series converges if and only
if the associated
definite integral,
the associated improper
definite integral converges.
So let's do the first one first.
What's the integral
associated with it?
Well, we take the
integrand, and, you know,
we-- frequently, we replace the
variable n with the variable x,
although that doesn't
really matter.
And so what we do, is we look at
the integral of this integrand
over the same region.
So in this case,
from 2 to infinity.
And so what we know is
that this sum converges if
and only if this integral does.
So then, the reason this
is a nice thing to do,
is that often
there are integrals
that are easy to compute,
while the associated series
are hard to compute.
So in this case,
this is an integral
that we have tools to
know, to compute with.
And in particular,
the tool that we have,
is that there's a simple
little substitution that
will work on this series.
So that's the substitution,
u equals log x.
So we make the substitution
u equals ln of x.
Then du is equal to
1 over x times dx.
So this is the integral of--
so 1 over x dx, that's du.
And so it's 1 over u du.
This is a definite
integral, so I also
need to change my bounds.
So when x is 2, u is ln of
2, although the lower bound
doesn't really matter very much
when we do the integral test,
because you know, if you
change it a little bit, that's
not going to change
the, you know--
as long as you don't
move it across a place
where the function explodes,
all the interesting stuff
is whether the function is
big as it goes to infinity.
So if you move a little
round at the bottom,
you'll change its
numerical value,
but you won't change whether
it converges or diverges.
But in any case, ln of 2.
And then when x
goes to infinity,
ln of x goes to infinity,
so the upper bound is also u
equals infinity.
And now this is
an easy integral.
This is just ln of
u between-- well,
ln 2, which again, really
doesn't matter, and infinity.
And we see that at
the upper bound,
we get ln of infinity,
which is infinity.
So this thing is infinity.
So our original series diverges.
OK.
So we've applied the
integral test here,
and we've found that
our series diverges.
What about this second one?
Well, here, we can again
apply the integral test,
the similar-looking integrand.
And in fact, so we
get-- so the integral
that we want to look at
is the integral from 2
to infinity of 1 over x
times log of x squared dx.
And the same substitution
is going to work here.
So we're going to use the
substitution u equals ln x,
du equals 1 over x times dx.
And the bounds are going to
be the same. ln 2 to infinity.
OK.
But what happens when we
make this substitution?
Well, the 1 over x
dx is still the du.
But then here, this time, we
have 1 over u squared, right?
Because we've got an ln of
x squared, and u is ln x.
So OK.
So we get 1 over u squared.
So again, this is
easy to integrate.
So this is 1 over u squared,
so that's going to be minus 1
over u when we integrate it
between ln 2 and infinity.
OK.
So we take the two values here,
as u goes to infinity, minus 1
over u goes to 0.
So this is 0 minus, and now with
the lower bound, it's minus 1
over ln 2, and
this is just ln 2.
So this integral converges to
a nice finite value, ln of 2,
so that means the sum
converges as well.
All right?
And in fact, if you go back
and look at the lecture video,
you'll see that you
can actually bound
the value of the sum in
terms of this value, ln of 2,
the value of the integral, and
the first terms of the sum.
I realized that I should
have said one thing
at the beginning,
which is that we didn't
check that the hypotheses of the
integral test are valid here.
So remember that the
integral test only
applies if this
function that you use
is a decreasing
positive function
on the interval in question.
And I didn't actually
check those conditions.
They're easy to see
in this case, right?
Because for n bigger than 2,
n is positive and increasing,
and log n is positive and
increasing, so the product is
positive and increasing, so
the 1 over it is positive
and decreasing.
So it's easy to
check, in this case,
that the conditions of
the integral test apply.
In the-- when you're doing
this out in the real world,
if you ever want to
apply the integral test,
that's something you should
check yourself before you
go and apply it to anything.
Make sure that you
really have a function
to which it does apply.
But then, once you have
a function to which it
does apply, especially if
it's a nice, easy-to-integrate
function like this, you
can easily apply it.
And in this case, we
applied it both directions.
We saw an integral where
the integral diverges,
and an integral where
the integral converges.
And so the corresponding sums,
the first one will diverge
and the second
one will converge.
I'll end there.